the new m1 mac chip from apple has been
blowing people's minds
because of how good the performance and
efficiency has been
and has been doing it while using the
arm v8 isa
or instruction set architecture which
was originally released
10 long years ago but just a couple of
weeks ago
arm announced the new version 9 isa
which will be the foundation for the
next decade of arm-based chips
so in this video i'm going to explain
all of the advantages of
rnv9 over the current v8 and then i'm
going to discuss
what this means for apple silicon max
and why this is such a huge deal for
apple
first off i'm 100 sure that apple is
working on designing
new apple silicon chips based on the new
arm v9 architecture
because apple was actually the very
first company
to design a chip based on the rmv8
architecture
which was released 10 years ago the main
benefit of rnv8 was that it switched
from using a 32-bit architecture
to 64-bit and shortly after it was
released
apple announced the a7 chip the very
first
64-bit iphone chip that went into the
iphone 5s
and this basically sparked a rally of
significant year-over-year performance
increases
with each and every new a series chip
from apple
all thanks to the new 64-bit arm
v8 architecture which eventually led to
the m1 mac
chip that we have today now before i get
into explaining the improvements of the
new rv9 instruction set architecture
i want to explain what that actually
means in the first place
so here's a simple explanation of modern
cpu instruction sets and how they work
by android authorities robert triggs
every computer out there
requires a cpu or processor
and cpus only work when they are given
very specific instructions
which is called the instruction set
traditional computer cpus like the ones
made by intel
currently use the x86 instruction set
which is a sisk design which stands for
complex instruction set computer cisc
cpus offer and support
many instructions which are very complex
since they can execute multiple
operations at once
among other factors but the downside to
this is that these
types of cisc cpus consume a ton of
power
which is fine when you're hooked up to
an outlet but it becomes a problem for
devices with
batteries like smartphones and that's
why there's
risk the reduced instruction set
computer architecture
risk cpus are much more simple since
they have a limited amount of
instructions
but the benefit of that is that they use
much less power
and that's why every single smartphone
built today uses a risk-based chip
so it gets as much battery life as
possible including the iphone
which has been using arm-based chips
which are based on risk
ever since the original iphone in 2017
apple released the iphone 7 with the a10
fusion chip
of course based on arm which was the
first iphone chip to feature both
performance cores
and efficiency cores using arm's new
dynam iq big little technology
which basically revolutionized the
industry because you can get
really high performance and great
battery life
within the same chip and that is exactly
what apple's
m1 chip uses for high performance cores
and four efficiency cores but the most
impressive part is that apple was able
to use
a risc based cpu design in a mac
with awesome software support and
performance that beats out
many complex cisc based chips which many
people
did not think was possible because risk
chips
were meant for simple workloads and not
mac computer workloads
but apple obviously nailed it and it's
about to get
even better thanks to arm v9 so let's
get into the new features
and the main advantages when arm
revealed v9
just a couple of weeks ago they claim
that users can expect a cpu performance
increase of 30 percent
over the next two generations of their
cpus which you can see right here in
this chart
thirty percent in the next two years and
the way they're gonna do it is by
offering new methods
to reduce memory latency and improve the
cpu frequency
bandwidth and cache so apple's own
arm-based chip designs
should be able to take advantage of
those new methods of increasing
performance
even without having to increase core
count thanks to rv9 but by far
the most important change for apple is
the introduction of
sve2 as the baseline feature of rnv9
cpus
sve stands for scalable vector
extensions
so let me explain what all of that means
currently the
m1 mac chip relies on neon which only
supports
single vector register instruction
lengths of 128 bits
so as you can see in this chart
comparing the performance of various
modes
of matrix computations the m1 chip on
the right
cannot even run some of the complex
tests because they exceed
the single 128-bit vector length that
neon
is limited to and for the orange bar
which uses a quad
32-bit instruction extension the m1 chip
uses
a special compiler that can convert it
into
a single 128-bit instruction
which it can then run but as you can see
the other x86 chips can easily run
more complex tasks like some of the 256
bit modes
or even 512 bit modes which require a
lot more power to run
so since the m1 chip currently only
supports 128 bit lengths
this creates a pretty huge issue for
apple especially if they want to release
an
apple silicon mac pro which will be used
by professionals
who need to run high-end and very
complex
scientific and mathematical workloads
which work
using those higher bit lengths and that
is where rmv 9's new
sve2 feature comes in which is a
scalable extension
with no fixed width sve 2 is able to
scale
vectors ranging anywhere from 128 to
2048 bits
down into 128 bit blocks which it can
then
process this will essentially allow
apple's future
m series chips to run those complex
tasks
that require wider bit lengths and apple
can even optimize their arm chips
and software for various bit lengths
like 128 or 256
for the apple watch or iphone all the
way up to 1024 or 2048
for a high-end mac pro which will
optimize it
for those very complex workloads so you
can bet
that the apple silicon mac pro will have
an
arm v9 based chip no doubt about it now
moving on
rv9 is also going to improve security
which apple is all about rmv9 introduces
a new
confidential compute architecture or cca
which creates realms which are secure
environments that various parts of the
code
run in that are separated from the os
and
the hypervisor so this essentially means
that your apps will run in a much more
secure state
so your sensitive data won't be able to
be accessed by the host machine
the hardware manufacturer the service
provider
or other software running on the device
or sharing the machine
and along with that rv9 is adding memory
tag
extensions which also help security by
identifying spatial and temporal memory
security issues
in software so to sum up the main
benefits of arm v9
it's gonna improve performance by up to
30 percent in two generations
it's gonna improve security and it's
going to allow arm-based chips to run
more complex workloads that use higher
bit lengths
now with all of that said i want to get
into what this means for apple
and how i think this is going to impact
the future apple silicon max
way back when apple announced the
transition to apple silicon
in june of 2020 and intact posted an
article saying that apple's transition
is a bit of an odd one because arm was
expected to announce their rv9
architecture
which they only just did a couple of
weeks ago but back then
either of two things was going to happen
either arm was literally just about to
announce
rnv9 and apple's mac chips would be the
first ones
on the new architecture or apple's mac
chips
would be stuck with the older arm v8
which we now know
is what ended up happening so here is my
theory on why apple chose
not to wait for rv9 for their very first
m1 max
apple knew that the performance jump
going from the old intel
chips to the new m1 chip would be
massive
with huge gains to everything from
performance to battery life
which we've shown off in our videos but
then the problem is that when
apple eventually updates those same base
level mac models
with second generation m2 chips there
would no longer be
anywhere near that big of an improvement
unless something
big changed and if the performance gains
won't be that big of a deal
then people that have the first gen m1
max wouldn't really have any reason to
upgrade to the new
m2 max so apple would have to think of a
way to make the m2 chips more appealing
and the perfect way to do that would be
to have the m2 chip
built using the new arm v9 architecture
as well as being built on a smaller
three nanometer
or four nanometer process compared to
the current
five nanometer m1 champ these two things
alone will give the m2 chips a
significant boost
in performance and efficiency even if
they stick to the same
8 core cpu design and keep in mind that
i'm talking about the base level m2 chip
and not the crazy 12 core or maybe even
16 core m1x chips
that we're expecting to come this year
in the higher end mac models
i personally believe that the m2 chip
will directly replace the m1
being meant for lower end machines like
the 2022
redesigned macbook air the base macbook
pro
and the base mac mini the same machines
that currently have the m1 chip
and the reason i think this is going to
happen because arm themselves
mentioned that the first gen r v9 cpus
will become available next year in 2022
and some sources believe that apple will
have the very first rmv9 chip
since apple's a7 chip was actually the
very first
rv8 chip so if this ends up happening it
definitely seems like arm is currently
in talks with apple
and they know that apple plans to have
their m2 chips ready next year
which seems extremely likely to happen
because arm did mention
that all existing software can run on
rmv9 based processors without any
problems
so because of that it's going to be
incredibly simple and well worth it for
apple to upgrade to arm v9
with the m2 chips which will give the
next gen max that we're expecting next
year
a nice jump in both performance and
efficiency
and of course the m2x and m2z or
whatever high-end chips they have
will also be built on the rmv9
architecture
especially the mac pro and then going
beyond the m2 chip
apple has a decent upgrade path because
when they eventually update the low end
apple silicon max again
potentially in 2023 or 2024
apple can simply make the m3 chips have
12 cores instead of the current eight
and by that time
they'll for sure be using three or maybe
even two nanometer chips from tsmc
which will further improve performance
and efficiency making for an easy
upgrade path
for at least three generations of max
and beyond so based on everything we
talked about in this video
the future for apple silicon max is
incredibly bright
and it looks like we're about to witness
a computing revolution
when these new chips start to roll out
and manufacturers begin to ditch
x86 chips and switch over to arm based
designs
so there you guys have it that's rnv9
explained
and if you learned something new from
this video go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there especially the intel
one thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video